et le César est attribué à
Bouli Lanners dans la nuit du 12 juin
des enquêteurs de la TG de Grenoble
canton de retrouver l'assassin d'une
jeune femme du mêlée par le feu en
pleine rue c'est le premier comédien
belge à s'imposer dans cette catégorie
de l'unique mold choisi pour la
générosité et l'humanité qui émane de
lui et qui correspondent à ce personnage
il avait déjà été nommé au César mais
Tom réalisateur pour Eldorado au
meilleur film étranger en 2009
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir je suis tellement content
c'était juste quel bonheur quelque chose
de pouvoir tourner dans ce film merci
Dominique Gilles Marchand quel bonheur
vraiment cette équipe merci je sais pas
quoi dire merci l'équipe Merci toute
l'équipe merci mes camarades de jeux mes
camarades de plateau
merci Carole Caroline toute l'équipe de
Eco d'avoir eu la bonne idée de produit
et le distribuer ce film merci Isabelle
Anaï Anne de ma compagnie de Python
d'année presque au quotidien et de
d'écouter mes élucubrations
existentielles et d'arriver à effacer le
syndrome d'imposture que je porte en
permanence sur moi et je suis va m'aider
et c'est grâce à vous que ce moment qui
est totalement improbable pour moi
je viens de Liège quand même
merci je vous aime
[Applaudissements]